on tuesday the city of las vegas will be
discussing the clark county code for
business licenses that allows cannabis
lounges to apply for legal businesses
licensed here in the valley jeremy j
ford is live at industrial sahara as the
public reacts to the possibility of
marijuana lounges jeremy
well here at the thrive cannabis
dispensary customers are busy
making purchases
as the sale for marijuana products
continues to rise across the valley some
folks feel a cannabis lounge is a step
in the right direction i spoke with
tourist trevor parker from alabama who's
in support of a smoker's lounge
i think that's a good idea i'll tell you
why you know what i'm saying because
there's some people that can't smoke in
their apartment complexes and places
like that you know what i'm saying so
they should be able to come out and you
know smoke
so i heard that i got a law that you
can't smoke in public if y'all get the
lounge
that'd be that'd be a clutch heavy
smokers like myself
now when asked what the disadvantages
would be parker told me there really
wasn't any and having lounges will
definitely make him visit again and i
was told by a local resident that he
believes that some casino owners are not
in support of cannabis lounges which is
why the process of getting them is slow
he said some fear tourists will spend
some less time
in the casinos and definitely
more time smoking marijuana
in las vegas jeremy j ford live
local now